inside the anti-corruption headquarters
of the French judicial police Michele
Platini was in the words of his advisors
answering all questions serenely and
precisely his lawyer declined to add
answers of his own ignoring reporters
outside but there remain a lot of
questions about one of the greatest
upsets in sport mine ears on from that
surprise announcement the eight stadiums
which will host the 2022 World Cup are
almost built but too many football fans
it's still a mystery how a tiny but
wealthy nation with little football
history could win the biggest prize of
all it's scorching climate meant that
the event has had to be moved from
summer to winter Michele Platini the
boss of Europe's governing body UEFA had
originally backed the United States as
host but he switched to support the
Middle Eastern country he is a chance
for Qatar is a chance for a part of this
a part of the world to receive the World
Cup is why I vote for them because they
never received the Hobart papers another
receives over cap why we why we can to
go to Qatar but for me was not a mistake
is not a mistake it was no regret but
critics suggests the decision to back
Qatar was made because of politics and
trade not for football reasons shortly
before the vote the then french
president nicolas sarkozy met Qatari
royalty and officials the Gulf State now
owns france's top football club Paris
Azure man even those who worked with and
admired Platini couldn't understand the
logic of his vote everybody questioned
why had they given this world cup to
Qatar given the Qatar didn't mean almost
any of the criteria that was required
and their own safety committee their own
advised against it FIFA's own safety
committee so I think there's always been
a big question mark over why did it go
to Qatar and inevitably
certain things get questioned including
were people persuaded by our legitimate
liens Michel Platini was once Europe's
best player a gifted goalscorer whose
move into football admin once looked so
promising but he remains banned from the
game because of his relationship with
the former head of FIFA Sepp Blatter a 1
million pounds payment from Blatter was
deemed unethical and stops Platini from
succeeding him as the boss of world
football as investigators continue to
dig into the past his fall from grace
may not yet be complete in woods Sky
News